denn die hat nicht so gesehen voll
peinlich
[Musik]
bis heute haben herz bekommen solle die
leute ich habe heute zwei special guest
neben mir und zwar danny und jacqueline
von cras schule für uns beide es ist ein
kleines comeback schon mal zusammen ein
video gemacht welchen video und jetzt
noch mal zu dritt heute 1 dennis freue
mich auch dass du heute dabei wird ganz
sicher die weitere in der beschreibung
verlegen checkt hier auf jeden fall ab
auf instagram und support die haben ein
paar folgen rausgesucht von dem morgen
sind gespannt was ihr dazu zu sagen habt
beende ihr seid jetzt gerade so gas
kappel oder nicht kachelmann weiß ist
nicht was bei kraft schule jetzt im
fokus steht deswegen so lustig wie in
alles in der welt kommen sie darauf
möchte ich einfach den lehrplan zu
verändern also soweit ich weiß ja steht
da noch was war da los
ich glaube wir haben was anderes
trainiert ja eigenmächtig den lehrplan
verändert das ist das ist schon mal ein
stück auf jeden fall nicht gegeben aber
ich wollte nicht tragen weil mit dem
handschuh
ja nee du hast ja nur zufällig gehört
du warst warst einfach auf dem gang
unterwegs halt in einem radius von 20
zentimeter und die tür aber damals
unterwegs
hast du gehört außerdem hat er richtig
guten unterwegs ich meine eher motiviert
schüler und bringt neue ideen
was soll ich da jetzt machen aber diese
lobhudelei da bleibt ja fast nichts
anderes übrig als den schilling mit
einem blauen auge davonkommen zu lassen
er sagte auch man das so sagen es ist
schon lustig euch so einer satire zu
sehen der andere setzt jetzt hierzu
neben mir sagte was was du der der
szenerie ist ist es die die
schulrektoren okay du hast jetzt gerade
bisschen um deinen job gebannt ich habe
nur ein wesen reihenweise junge menschen
in lebensgefahr gebracht hast du hast
das quasi mord begangen durch den
lehrplan wechsel verständlich löwen
pflaster da ich konnte dann jedoch nicht
hängen lassen er war die ganze zeit
verletzt du mir was ein mann also ich
glaub ich hab ich ein bisschen verknallt
was also dass schon eine art trio hat
ihr gefallen im moment ja ja und dann
setzt man sich auch dafür ein
totalausfall ist einfach gefallen
schuldig seien im nachhinein ich muss
dir wirklich danken ich meinen du hast
mädchen aus gerätes nicht zu danken dass
mir auch geholfen sonst hätte ich mir
sicher den angebrochen
ja sie alles gesehen was ich dachte ja
das beste löwen genau hier hinten bio
physik chemie raum genauer angesehen und
eventuell an hatte ich auch kein
bisschen
wieso christian nämlich nicht einfach
ich weiß das ist auch möchte also eher
hinten sitzen also jetzt mal so rein
logisch überlegt so du hast ja gerade
hast du deinen job das geld das sie
jetzt vor schluss musste was ganz
anderes bekommen ist einfach nur aus der
tür von präparaten die gleiche schülerin
ist also ja zu starten war ausrichten
also wird die logik so hat gerade so
fasst seinen job riskiert dass ihr dann
zusammenhalt eure zukunft aufbauen
könnte in der arbeitslos ist dann weil
er sich dann geküsst kurz oder
langfristige verschlechterung des
eigenen lebens genau das darf nicht
passieren ich hätte mich fast auf sie
eingelassen
ich darf sie einfach nicht küssen sich
seine schülerin und ich bin jemand
mitarbeiter der schule
ich muss so war also aber arbeit knapp
also es war auch klar sagen wie lustig
auch so zu sehen sie hier
ihr habt eure angehört immer beides du
die augen zu und das stinkt geblieben
ich habe noch nie gesehen dass so ein
kurs abgebrochen wird also wenn sie kurz
abgebrochen dann ist bei mir sollte man
guckt sich so an und denkt es ja jetzt
dann macht man es halt nicht aber dass
man so auch schon so tun als euch so
gesagt und nach der 2 ja ich habe
gestern das mittagessen büchern zu
stellen
eingeschickt erhöht was machst du
schmeißt eintopf runter ist ein topf bis
in die schüssel ist das ärgerlich
ungeschickt unabsichtlich alles gut ich
hol dir was zum server machen
es ist echt so kommt also einerseits ist
da ist wieder so ein witz
die linse die darüber erwartet und ich
hoffe erbsen und linsen aber
verschiedene sachen halt nie
funktioniert funktioniert das eigentlich
kommt eine entscheidet ihr die super
drüber
er hat ja so trocken geprobt oder habt
ihr erst mal so drei kleider schmutzig
gemacht bei den proben schon trocken
bookassist ist der boden dann auch in
der einstellung drin also haben wir dem
boot über sauber gemacht dann ja wieder
was gelernt leute also ein topf um
schmeißer wird der boden nicht mal
gekürzt
so gesehen peinlich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir wussten vor den vertretungslehrerin
ausziehen
er bekommt er gleich wieder rein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wohin wolltest du denkst du was dabei
genau also eigentlich müsste man ja mit
dem schwarzen kleid dann doch auch in
den anderen raum wo die sachen sind und
da ja dumm gelaufen
einfach einfach ein kleines missgeschick
von ihr herz hast du einfach nicht
nachgedacht da blickt also derselbe
[Gelächter]
jetzt wird die frage die ich möchte galt
der blick
jacqueline oder was war das jetzt
natürlich der herbst sich vorher noch
nicht gesehen in der form in ihrer
ganzen pracht so auf den bund
gerichte wie wollt ihr da jetzt
eigentlich wieder raus also leute auf
jeden fall die beiden sind unter
beschreibung von vielen dank fürs
mitmachen so weit bin sehr gespannt wie
sich das mit euch noch weiter entwickeln
wird und an der stelle leute haben die
beiden ab